[Musique]
extrait émouvant du film we are marshall
mettant en vedette matthew mais canaris
il ya neck les événements tragiques qui
ont inspiré ce film là reviennent à
l'avant scène ce week end
oui mais tu mets canaris qui joue
l'entraîneur jack et linguère dans ce
film-là jack lang vial qui a été
l'entraîneur qui a accepté de rebâtir le
programme de football de l'université
marshall en 1971 un an donc après le
tragique événement dont on commémore les
50 ans aujourd'hui
alors ça se passait le 14 novembre 1970
le plus la plus importante projet dit
dans le monde du sport frappe
l'université de marchaux d'après un
match en caroline du nord le temps de
ring rule de prend place dans un avion
75 personnes sont à bord et personne ne
rentrera à la maison 37 joueurs huit
entraîneurs entre autres ont perdu la
vie dans cet accident d'avion tout au
long de la semaine l'université masciola
souligner l'événement tragique notamment
en remettant des diplômes à titre
posthume aux étudiants qui devaient
graduée cette année-là des
commémorations qui ont aussi eu lieu à
la fontaine en hommage aux victimes
puis les joueurs actuels du tarn de
ringgold ont porté le nom de toutes les
victimes sur leur casque
hier lors d'un match à l'affrontement à
disputer contre mais drôle tennessee
faut dire que ça va bien pour les femmes
de ringe de cette saison six victoires
et aucun revers hier évidemment vous en
doutez douze mille cinq cents personnes
dans les gradins et beaucoup d'émotion
une victoire à sens unique 42 14 en
faveur de marcheurs les joueurs ont
d'ailleurs soulevé leur casque à la fin
de la rencontre en hommage aux victimes
donc 50 ans aujourd'hui pour ce tragique
événement qui a marqué évidemment toute
une génération
nous va merci beaucoup yannick il dit